thrilled to have back on the show a man
who i interviewed on march 1st
and here we are uh in the the uh
the end of the first week of of april
uh in our um calendar year 2021
and he is now a national champion head
coach
of baylor basketball he is scott drew
coach drew thanks for calling into the
show
well thanks for having me back on thanks
for your advice on march 1st it worked
yes you're gonna have a lot of people
calling you on march first every year
i bet so i bet so we call that you know
what we call that coach we call it the
rich eisen show bump
we've had people on this show who have
uh won
oscars after being on the show and
emmy's being out
it doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if it's immediate or long-term we
just take
credit for it so i appreciate you
tacitly
giving some to us too i appreciate it
appreciate what you guys do
and obviously greatly appreciate what
you and your guys have done
and what they what what you did um if
i had told you the day that you were
hired
uh at baylor and everything that was
going on in the program
that your vision would be eventually
realized in 2021 you would have said
what
on that day coach uh it's going to take
that long
because when you're young you're
probably dumb you know and you're a
little naive and uh
um i i tell you what we had uh uh so
much success though in 2010 you go to
the elite eight you lose to the national
champion you're like
man we could have won a national
championship and we'd even know it right
and then 2012
you wish to kentucky in the lead eight
they win a national championship
and you're like we're right there and
then and then it takes some time to get
back
to a chance to play for a final four and
then
then you break through and i tell you
what it does is it it does
uh um teach you to appreciate it that
much more because
when you're close and don't get
something and then it comes later
you you really you really know it's a
blessing and and that's where
god's plan is always best and uh uh when
you when you get there you want to take
advantage
of that opportunity because there's a
lot of great teams programs coaches
that never get to a final four or win it
all and hats off to our players that
really uh uh
help bring it home and so uh let's let's
talk about that
uh and what did you tell your team prior
to the national championship game what
did you what did you say i guess in that
hoosiers moment maybe in the locker room
there in the state of indiana
where everybody's gathered we all know
that gonzaga had history on the line we
all know that certainly everybody
certainly on this show and everybody in
the media was talking about the
the big finish of the game after your
victory against houston your blowout win
everyone was talking about gonzaga and
how mark few would get his guys up what
did you say to your
team in that locker room well
to be honest with the uh uh by the time
we got to that locker room
um i i thought our guys were prepared
and
uh they deserved the credit from uh
we you're given once you advance each
round a couple days of practice
and our team really got after those
couple days of practice each week and we
kept improving we kept getting better
and we needed to coming off that three
week pause um
so to me every every battle's won before
it's fought and
everyone knows sun tzu the art of war
but it's so true there's no
magical uh uh speech or or pill
uh uh no advil is gonna get you that
victory right before you walk out
now obviously i'm an energetic person
yes and uh
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try to make sure
they're motivated but uh that battle was
won
in that week of practice leading up to
it their preparation and all the film
sessions leading up to it and then uh
the one thing that that
that uh was great is i thought
they understood two things one how how
much uh the baylor
family cared about him loved him and uh
they had a chance to make history
um be in the being the first baylor
basketball team to win a national
championship
they also understood history uh to be
the second school in the state of texas
to win a national championship
and the first one they did a movie on in
1966
so i mean they they knew how big this
opportunity was
and they knew you can't just say well
you know what in the future we'll get
back
because every year is different and uh
um uh
uh jericho angelo actually uh had a
recorded message that that was
tremendous just to bring in that that
point home
uh to him just you gotta take advantage
of these opportunities and
uh credit our guys for being locked in
we really
really each week i thought got better
and played better
and and that's a tribute to our players
so you played a recording from jerry
colangelo for the team
before they went out that was part of
the pre-game uh
no no that that was done earlier in the
week um we do we like
like one thing beautiful about the
bubble is there aren't many distractions
right so besides our guys doing homework
and then getting really good at connect
four
and cornhole uh we were able to have
several uh
film sessions and talk uh a team time
opportunities where we could really bond
grow appreciate one another learn more
about one another
and then and then obviously uh uh
because of zoom
and video nowadays you can you can have
a ton of guest speakers
and uh tony dungy uh offered a great
message to our team as well and
uh appreciative of the guys that uh
communicated with our guys
scott drew here on the rich eisen show
one thing that i definitely
noticed about your team that certainly
um
you know everybody uh learned in march
madness if they hadn't followed your
team throughout the year
scott it's just how tireless
your team is i mean tireless on every
possession there was never a let up
never whether it's crashing the boards
or switching on defense or
using a transition opportunity to your
advantage to making the open
shot how do you how do you coach that
how do you how do you
foster something like that and or
recruit for it because it seems like
there's a like-mindedness of
everybody on your team great question so
the first thing is the staff deserves a
lot of credit for recruiting that
because
at the end of the day um you have to
have the right people on the bus
and the second part is our staff i think
assistant coaches do a great job or
strength coach or trainer
in making sure that they're able to keep
improving
and getting better each and every day of
practice and throughout the year
and then the players deserve a lot of
the credit for their hard work time and
sacrifice because everybody practices
the same amount of time
because ncaa limitations where you get
better are those people that come back
in the gym they're
there early in the morning they're
they're early
late at night we got guys that just uh
uh they're gym rats and they love to be
in there with their teammates
iron sharpens iron they love to get
better and so they're the ones putting
in the work
uh with that uh one key i think to our
success was our starting rotation too
we have a lot of depth on our team and
when you're when you're playing when
people go to the bench there's usually a
drop-off we go to the bench
and a lot of times we we we get better
because as you know
each and every night is not going to be
your night shooting wise and you got to
have
multiple people that can can get you 20
points and uh that eight-man rotation
that we put in that's a starting
rotation in our mind
and those that allows you to play harder
when you're in
because you know when you go to the
bench uh um someone else is going to
come in and help the team
you don't have to save yourself you
don't have to conserve or take plays off
uh to go extended time because you can
give everything knowing
someone's got your back when they come
in was there a point in the game on
on monday night coach where you're like
oh gosh this this i
you know this is exactly the way i
wanted it to play out obviously you're a
coach and you're always looking for that
trap door you're always looking to make
sure that
nobody uh already reads their newspaper
clippings just
five ten minutes in the game i mean
you're up 11-1 first tv timeout 29-10
um you know a 9-2 run thrown on you but
you're still
up by 10. uh and then your guys respond
uh with damn near a tenno run itself
when when gonzaga cuts it to nine
at what point did you actually have
maybe have a dawn on your allowed to
dawn on you like this is actually
happening
for you when you're in coaching mode
thanks to uh uh a sports center nowadays
you see all these great comebacks and
you're like praying and it's not your
team
right that you give up one of those
comebacks too so uh
really when both teams emptied the bench
at that point i knew uh uh
i knew we we we met our goal and we'd
reached that finish line
and god had blessed us with the national
championship and then of course
your family being there you know i was
talking about this with jim nance on
monday before the game
scott drew that you know you know your
brother making a shot drawn up by your
dad for valpo
in 1998 is still to this day and forever
will be
one of the greatest moments in the
history of march madness and now here
you are
uh with your team um building a program
that was in
absolute shambles when you took it over
uh unprecedentedly so
there was a coven problem for your team
this year in a pandemic there was
uh a once-in-a-lifetime snow and ice
storm
that uh racked your coaching staff as
you had mentioned to us
uh more than the members of the team uh
when that happened
now here you are as you mentioned the
first texas team since glory road
texas western to win it all what was it
like to be with your family
and talk about all this uh after you
achieved
the the the greatest moment of your
coaching career
coach well i i can i can tell you when
you have those special moments those
great moments they're not
great and special unless you have people
to share it with and
uh on the floor being able to hug
everybody that was a part of it that was
huge
and then after the game being able to
see i mean uh
shoot yeah i wasn't able to hug my wife
and kids for four weeks
so because we went from kansas city to
to uh uh
indianapolis and can't thank the ncaa
enough for giving us the
the ncaa tournament i mean as a coach
everyone would tell you the year ago
before if your team was going to the
tournament
you went in that locker room and said
season's over that was really hard to do
because most
most most kids aren't playing in the nba
this is it they spend their entire
childhood
preparing for those moments to play in
the ncaa tournament and then when they
have a chance to get them and they're
taken away
i mean that's hard so we got to thank
the ncaa for all the safety
requirements all the medical fields the
schools from paying for all that to
provide a safe tournament but
being able to hug them for the first
time in four weeks
and then obviously uh uh um my dad
brother have been
been there for for uh all all the good
moments bad moments
and when you're in march madness you're
gonna have some of the best moments your
life you're gonna have some of the
toughest moments your life and that's
why it's march madness
in 40 minutes anything can happen the
best team doesn't always win
i was just we were just blessed that it
was us um uh
on that monday night again just your dad
what do you say to your
your father or coach like that i mean
yeah you know what like
you just hug at that point when you when
you when you hug and embrace you know
all those words coming through
with that with that emotion who did you
hear from
um that you know from text or or a call
that you had nerd for
a while or drop a name for us here who
might have reached out to you
well i mean i mean first of all you're
i'm one of those guys like if you get a
text message or email
i i got to get back to you so uh
you're you're obviously over a thousand
text messages over
300 emails and everything else and
you're getting back to everybody and
then once you
go to bed the next day they're right
back up but what what it allows you to
do is
you hear from a lot of like uh uh baylor
alums and fans and people have been
there
all through the thick and thin from the
old players like david wesley brian
skinner cherry teagle
um to to rg three to um
uh alums like that john lee hancock the
movie director but it also
it allows you to reconnect with with old
uh i mean
back in the day you know when we were
kids growing up you you
when you moved away you didn't you
didn't really stay friends with people
because you
couldn't see them nowadays you get a lot
of text and
email from grammar school kids that used
to hang out with they just went i don't
know if you remember me but
um so it's great to reconnect with with
all them as well
and i'm sure what about the the
the kids that you refer to uh that were
first in for you
as you were rebuilding the program oh it
was
those are just a given because i mean
all throughout the the season and year
we see
before covet every summer the guys come
back and then uh obviously during the
year they can make it to games you see
them
um and then uh like when we won the
first big 12 championship in 71 years
uh we made sure that um they knew just
how much we appreciated and loved and
how much they put in it
uh justin hoff did a great video um
before
uh our championship game and it showed
some highlights of our past players and
just
uh you guys are standing on their
shoulders for the foundation and hard
work they put in
to get us to this opportunity and to see
their excitement
um and to see their pride um that that
that's
coaching is like parenting your
christmas time your kids opening
presents they're happy
you're happy you know and that's it when
you see everybody happy and the great
thing is
i woke up today and i'm like all right
who do we got what's the practice wait a
minute we're done
we don't have to scout we don't have to
schedule we won that championship yes
no one's going to take that away from
you man no one will do that and
you know you'd mentioned again we we
talked about it the last
texas team to win a title in men's
basketball
uh was the texas western teen of 1966
and they made a movie of it as you know
about cold glory road and there's a
you know and the reason for that is is
so many
uh about the story and and it was
historic certainly
uh of uh on a um an american in a racial
uh standpoint but let's let's just say
that anybody
who's a men's basketball team in the
state of texas
has a movie made about them who do you
want to play you in the film
i don't know if hollywood got anyone
ugly enough for me but
i'll let them figure out the future that
i tell you what was great
our athletic director mack rhodes had
actually worked at utep
and was great friends with uh don
haskins so uh
he was able to share that story uh to
our team
uh just the last team that won and it's
it's it's it's amazing when uh
uh uh how people do forget history
though
and uh man 196 no one was i mean none of
our players obviously were born during
then
most of us coaches weren't born during
then and then and when they when they
said glory road a couple of guys
so it's just amazing how uh uh how long
ago that was and
for a state that has had so many great
uh
basketball players and we got so many
great high school teams aau teams
college teams junior college teams
um and i see more and more championships
in the future coming from the state
but uh uh really happy for the state too
so
uh coach appreciated the call on march
1st
um let's i guess that's now we've got to
do it every year
right i mean yeah and you know what on
the phones those calendars are easy to
just make sure every year they pop up
right
that's right they'll have a memory and
we'll have a memory pop up on your phone
now
uh and congratulations really appreciate
it thanks for the call
well please appreciate you and thanks
for that advice on march 1st
you got it scott drew everybody yes
indeed blessed day
baylor head basketball coach hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here